good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight the month long saga
turned nightmare of Brett Kavanaugh a
Supreme Court confirmation process
finally coming to a conclusion the
Senate voted narrowly today to move the
decision to the floor that means the
final vote on this on Kavanagh will take
place tomorrow probably tomorrow
afternoon this is almost over
Democrats made one final push against
Cavanaugh this afternoon screaming
protesters swarmed the capital famous
journalists became completely hysterical
on Twitter check the blue checks and you
will see for yourself and then Dianne
Feinstein the 85 year old ranking
Democrat on the Senate Judiciary
Committee someone long holding a
reputation for being reasonable
abandoned that reputation and went all
the way she suggested that Brett
Kavanaugh isn't simply a bad nominee or
a bad jurist but he is a violent and
dangerous person there's part of it at
the hearing last week we saw a man
filled with anger and aggression judge
Kavanagh raised his voice he interrupted
senators this behavior revealed a
hostility and belligerence that is
unbecoming of someone seeking to be
elevated to the United States Supreme
Court
lock that man up well for much of the
day Brett Kavanaugh as fate seemed
uncertain in ping-pong back-and-forth
Republican senator Lisa Murkowski of
Alaska wound up voting with the
Democrats and then she issued a bizarre
statement in which he said that
Cavanaugh is a good man but should not
be on the Supreme Court
in other words Brett Kavanaugh was
falsely accused of gang rape and that
false accusation means he can't be a
Supreme Court justice because false
accusations are disqualifying for the
victims of them keep in mind at least
Rakowski is an actual US senator hard to
believe but true and then in the mid
afternoon something remarkable happened
something that very few expected senator
Susan Collins of Maine one of the most
liberal Republicans in Washington and
not someone famous for memorable oratory
took to the Senate floor to mount a
rigorously logical defense of
Cavanaugh's character ability and
nomination here's part of what she said
the facts presented do not mean that
president that Professor Ford was not
sexually assaulted that night
or at some other time but they do lead
me to conclude that the allegations
failed to me be more likely than not
standard therefore I do not believe that
these charges can fairly prevent judge
Kavanaugh from serving on the court mr.
president
I will vote to confirm judge Kavanaugh
Thank You mr. president this was not an
emotional speech and for that reason it
was very different from virtually
anything we've heard for the past month
it was an argument rooted in reason and
it had a huge effect the dam broke
almost immediately after West Virginia
Democrat Joe Manchin announced that he
too will support Kavanagh Manchin gives
the nomination the necessary 50 votes
even if protestors find Jeff Flake again
and scream at him once more the
nomination will go through barring some
unforseen event and we've got to be
honest that could happen but if it
doesn't Brett Kavanaugh will become a
Supreme Court justice this weekend
now for the crime of representing his
own voters back in West Virginia who
overwhelmingly support Cavanaugh senator
Manchin was surrounded tonight by the
youth wing of his own party and ritually
denounced in the halls of the Capitol as
is common now nobody tried to stop them
or even ask them to be quiet because
we're getting used to mob rule here
Watch
[Applause]
these kinds of scenes are everywhere in
Washington tonight we're sad to tell you
the left has given up on making its own
case activists no longer try to convince
anyone of anything
instead they scream and bully as a
tactic this can be effective it worked
for many years for the Mafia for example
but there is a cost to it especially
when it's on television
normal people find it scary and
unreasonable because that's exactly what
it is scary and unreasonable the left is
going too far
and it's alienating even liberal
Republicans like Susan Collins I am
thinking in particular not at the
allegations raised by Professor 4 but of
the allegation that when he was a
teenager Judge Cavanaugh drugged
multiple girls and used their weakened
state to facilitate gang rape this
outlandish allegation was put forth
without any credible supporting evidence
that outlandish story Center Collins is
referring to of course was all over the
other cable channels repeated
uncritically for weeks it was of course
a fantasy was promoted by stormy
Daniels's attorney the world's creepiest
porn lawyer who is now by the way a
leading Democratic presidential
candidate that tells you anything about
the moment we're living in he creepy
porn lawyer lashed out at Susan Collins
on Twitter today he calls her speech
quote entirely disingenuous and shameful
but by this point even Democrats were
starting to understand that the freak
show they have unleashed is beginning to
hurt them Ken Vogel at the New York
Times even wondered aloud on Twitter if
the creepy porn lawyer might be quote a
double agent all along working for the
Republicans unlikely but he's helped
them out in the field though they never
got the memo the one about trying to see
non-crazy for the sake of not scaring
the voters progressive leader Linda
Sarsour spoke for many on the left when
she attacks Susan Collins for the color
of her skin
quote senator Susan Collins is the
mother and grandmother of white women in
America who gave us a Donald Trump
presidency whatever that means they're
all saying it over a GQ magazine writer
Sophia Boyd
wrote this quote if I ever die from
getting an illegal abortion please drop
my body off at senator Collins's house
and let it rot well if there's one thing
we've learned during the last month
it's what the activists left really
thinks and a lot of people are scared by
what they really think though actually
the term think may be too generous a lot
of what we're hearing isn't the product
of thinking at all it's the product of
coordinated instructions handed down
from on high and dutifully repeated by
angry children liberals are party people
they do exactly what they are told watch
this scene today from Capitol Hill which
really says it all let's go watch the
vote
I'm going to go to office she's on our
side
repeat after me and like the little
robots they are they do during her
speech Susan Collins noted that Supreme
Court nomination battles have become
steadily angrier and more vicious over
the course of 30 years she said she
hopes what happened to Brett Kavanaugh
is rock bottom and it gets better from
here
of course we and a lot of other people
hope she's right we worry that she isn't
the effort to destroy Brett captain's
life failed apparently but only barely
nobody important seems to regret what
happened to him Norm's like the
presumption of innocence and basic
fairness the ones this country is built
on remain intact but they've been
damaged they may crumble if they are
attacked again will they be well that
really depends on voters voters reward
mob justice in November the screaming
robots you just saw on your screen we're
gonna get more of it because that's the
way the system works
you voters reject it the Democrats may
rethink the strategy and get back to
arguing on behalf of what they say they
believe which would be a massive
improvement over sending out their youth
wing to scream at people for once these
midterms really matter they will
determine the course of the Democratic
Party going forward